seen by many as a polarizing figure in
indonesia
after ignoring police requests to come
in for questioning he turned himself
into authorities over accusations of
breaching covert 19 protocols
god permits i can come to the jakarta
police to attend the investigation into
me
in accordance with the law
rizik returned to indonesia last month
after three years of self-imposed exile
in saudi arabia
thousands of supporters showed up at the
airport to welcome the leader of the
islamic defenders front or fpi
back to jakarta since then he's been
involved in several events that drew
large crowds
including his daughter's wedding
he didn't come for questioning when we
asked him the first time or the second
time
we stated that we would arrest him but
today he has come here
rizik is accused of ignoring covert 19
protocols by hosting large events
in a country with more than 600 000
confirmed covert 19 cases
but human rights organizations say
they're concerned there is more to this
case
than just health violations we have an
increasing concern
about the increasing crackdowns
by indonesian government towards the
islamists
or those perceived to be the islamists
the radicals islam and you know
those who are um not in not aligned with
the the government uh meta narrative of
nationalism
in its early years the fbi was accused
of vigilantism
targeting night spots western embassies
and some minority communities
fpi is considered a hardline
organization by many
and although its membership is
significantly smaller than mainstream
religious
groups its leaders are able to organize
large demonstrations
when thousands took to the streets in
2017 to protest against the governor of
jakarta
a christian ethnically chinese man over
allegations of blasphemy
ryzek shihab was seen as a key figure in
the demonstrations
that were viewed as a challenge to
indonesia's secular identity
before traveling to saudi arabia risik
was charged under the country's
pornography laws
those charges were later dropped now he
could face six years in prison for
violating covert 19 regulations
the concern over this next period will
be precisely how
the government manages what it clearly
it's clear that they see them as a
political problem
how they manage the perception that
they're actually using other laws
to repress a group for political reasons
rather than the fact that they've
actually broken the law
days ago police shot dead six alleged
supporters of friezak
police say the men were armed with guns
and a sword
indonesia's national human rights
commission is investigating the incident
and whether the killings were lawful and
police in jakarta say
they will continue their own
investigations into rezik
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta